[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
podcast welcome back
um today we want to do something a
little bit different and that is
you know since we've got this uvo we've
been thinking a lot about
we don't we don't want to be the only
ones to experience this right
right right you know and so there's
actually this like legendary
am radio host um his name's terry
carnation you know he's been doing that
show 32 years
32 years and actually he's been doing it
so long he took a break
and now he's he's doing a podcast
actually yeah it's called dark
air um i mean it's it he covers a lot of
different things right it's like
it's mostly paranormal stuff yeah it's
like you know ghosts and he's an expert
on all that stuff
yeah and we thought like we're up here
now we have proof that some of this
stuff exists like aliens for example i
mean they're running the food court you
guys know that
yeah we thought we'd like to expose
someone else to
proof yeah who better yeah than terry
carnation i mean
why wait any longer candice can we beam
up terry carnation please
collecting terry
[Music]
that's always got that weird it does i
know it's a little jarring it's a little
bit jarring we don't blame you if you're
a little bit thrown off by that
yeah sorry it's uh where the [ __ ] am i
well okay you know what a ufo is right
yes i am aware right so we got this and
you know just because a little bit
younger we decided to call it a uvo
you know unidentified vibing object oh
where are manners i'm so sorry
i don't i don't know cody millennial
noel we are tmg
and uh we also run a podcast but we do
it from space and so we beamed you up
here
just to yeah yeah i'm in outer space yes
we're floating on a planet earth yeah
it's uh
i know be alien or humanoid
oh us oh we're definitely human
we're human for sure for sure i mean
like i said this is
a podcast and so this is a human podcast
are you saying aliens couldn't
participate in a podcast oh they
definitely could
how do i know that you're not an alien
in human form
ah that's a good question actually what
can humans do that aliens can't
i can do this no aliens can probably do
that
yeah yeah if you are
aliens i know what happens on board
alien ships
to humans what's that what
i just want to say that i understand
that you need to do
what you need to do so go ahead and do
it
um he thinks we're going to go on his
ass oh probing that that's kind of like
a meme
anal probes are real have been verified
in thousands of abductees
i mean we don't have any probes yeah we
don't
have anything i see many things you
could probe me with
oh yeah mannequin fingers yeah i guess
there's a there's a bowling trophy
matter of fact
we should show them the [ __ ] it there is
this
oh dear lord but we we've never probed
this is a proverb we've never probed
anyone with this we've never
used it yeah i swear i swear we're not a
probing this isn't a probing
thing i i just i just have to say upon
seeing what's what's this entitled this
is called the [ __ ] it
it's like a boppit but with sex toys
yeah you know it's got a lot of
different
maneuvers just kind of yeah there's a
there's a lot of number of different
options there
yeah i just want to say that um
if you need to probe me i'm i'm on board
let's let's do this
let's get ready oh i mean it's not you
know
no i'm just saying i'm i'm a willing
participant so you want to be probed
i wouldn't say i want to be probed but
i've always wondered what it would be
like i've heard
so many stories for 32 years
right on my late night am paranormal
call-in show
dark air with terry carnation i have
heard
hundreds of stories of
a middle-aged man driving through a
cornfield late at night in
in kansas all of a sudden he hears he
hears a noise he sees a bright
white light surrounding his ford f-150
and and all of a sudden the car stalls
and he's
he's sucked up into some kind of
interstellar vortex finds himself on an
alien ship
he is then summarily probed in his anus
now i'm
i have never been sure why aliens are so
obsessed with the human anus
i mean if you want to look around inside
of a human body
you could go in through the mouth that's
true i mean
there are those guys that we met like
like a few weeks ago i mean they go
through both does that involve that not
this they got a special other device
it's crazy they go both
dp double probe yeah oh it's brutal what
galaxy are they from
five oh i'm not familiar but that sounds
that sounds intense i have to say that
if you need to go in
both orifices i i too am i'm ready for
that
no we i mean i mean we you know would
you say you've heard
a ton of stories would you say it's a
prerequisite for
us like should we be probing all of our
guests if you want to be taken seriously
i think that every interview should
begin with an anal probe
i mean i guess we'll walk kyle can we
get a go
candice can we get an anal probe flown
in
candace yes
uh anal probe ordering off of amazon
it takes a while to get here is it on
prime what's the delivery
yeah oh excellent all right so i'm going
to just go with the fact that you're not
aliens and i'm not getting probed
dodged a bullet there dodged a probe
rather would you say you know
uh as far as your you know your
paranormal experience
where would you classify aliens in sort
of this you know
space like would you call this more
paranormal or would it be
more of its own thing well i think
people
misunderstand the word paranormal
anything paranormal is just
outside of the normal gen z
podcasters inhabiting a an orbiting
space station um who may or may not be
aliens
this is outside of the normal so
unidentified flying objects it
incorporates
um something strange you might have seen
certainly there's cryptids
like loch ness monster and and bigfoot
and the
chupacabra um the swamp ape
uh but and it certainly involves the
the spectral and supernatural ghosts
specters
the the undead um evil
uh the possibilities of satanic forces
at work
in the world as a gen z podcast
um which would you mention the swamp ape
you said
yeah out of all the paranormal
characters i guess which do you think is
the most lit
when you say lit do you mean woke no lit
is like
lit it's like it's like lit
explain lit it's tight it's like awesome
tight like an anus or no um
like a yeah like part you know cool cool
i understand okay yeah cool
yeah cool cool so cool is lit yeah but
lit is not woke
no no the most lit let's um
i'm going to go with um demonic
possession okay yeah
demonic possession when you are
encompassed by some kind of satanic
force uh that which inhabits your body
it doesn't get more lit than that
if you ever it's true you ever partied
with someone who's been possessed
that's totally yeah they go ape [ __ ]
yeah they definitely go wild swamp
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] exactly not to be
confused
with like literal swamp ape [ __ ] because
that's like a whole other
that's just foul i've smelled swamp ape
[ __ ] before and believe me you do not
want to go there
however it makes an excellent mulch
maybe we could get some of that mulch if
we
oh we should beam up a swamp ape next
time and probe it
if we can find one i mean that's true oh
they're there
are they they are um yeah right right
down there everglades
ah you mentioned paranormal experiences
you know and we're talking a lot about
anal probing
do ghosts ever you know
probe someone ha perhaps in their ass
have you heard of any stories like that
you're obsessed with the human anus
he's not an alien let me say that
spectral forces
um can interact with humans uh in many
different ways uh we had an episode
recently where a young gentleman had a
ghost
of a woman uh and her name was happened
to be
karen karen the ghost inhabited
his house and she started well passive
aggressively controlling him
trying to get him to lose weight you
know if he would go for a second bowl of
cereal in the morning she would push the
bull onto the floor
and would shatter in front of him she
would roll the yoga ball out from the
garage
as kind of a like hint hint maybe get
your ass into shape they ended up in a
relationship
wow and they were fully fully sexual
with one another and um and it's a ghost
it is a ghost how do you be sexual with
a ghost yeah
oh he's gonna oh
got it i think i broke your mannequin
got it
so pretty standard yeah standard is do
you insert your penis in the
right
you may not feel much at first
sure you have to use a great deal of
your imagination you know what i mean
cuckoo but you're saying there is such a
thing as
as ghost [ __ ] can i say that
ghost [ __ ] that's an excellent band
name yeah it really is yeah
screaming ghost [ __ ] yeah i have to a
a confession to make which is
you know many people ask me terry
um what started your interest in the
paranormal and the supernatural
and um it actually boils down to the
fact
that i was did you ever see the movie uh
ghost dad
with uh bill cosby
haven't seen it in 1987 no he who shall
not be named bill cosby
yeah practically voldemort these days
yeah he made an exquisite film called
ghost dad
about well a dead ghost
yes being a dad ghost exactly i was
raised by a ghost mom
really tell us about that how so yeah
when i was about three years old uh my
mother
left my father and i um
she had some kind of an affair with um
wouldn't wood floor installer guy was
that like a carpenter
no but just specifically wood floors do
you choose the different kind of grains
or textures you want
and then whether you want it to be like
a tile or whether it's
actual hardwood or what have you and
then they buff it out and
it's excellent you could use some wood
floors up here yeah
yeah we've considered it's just after we
spent all the money buying the ships so
yeah now we're saving again for
renovations so
she took off rumor was that
she died she may have died but she came
back to life
in our house and i was living with my
father
and then there i was four or five years
old and my
ghostly spectral mother appeared in
front of me and she raised me
wow did you find that as like as you got
older and as you were a teenager did you
find it hard to sort of like
you know do typical teenager things like
maybe you want to sneak out hang out
late
you know it was challenging it was
definitely challenging i mean we had a
beautiful relationship
the most difficult thing was how
everyone doubted us no one believed that
she was real
uh my father thought that she was some
kind of imaginary friend
you know dr schneiderman was convinced
that
she was of some kind of figment of my
imagination
and it's not fair and
i know she was real and we oh we laughed
together we would um we would hug
and she would make blueberry pancakes
for me every morning
well what's your favorite terry
blueberry pancakes coming right up
now it was a little awkward she didn't
have
hands right um because she was
spectral she couldn't pick up the
spatula right right so i would have to
make them
for us oh okay um but she did my laundry
um which i would have to do i would have
to do
but she was really in hands but she was
really doing it she just her hands would
go right right
right through the socks and right
through the meundies and did you ever
get bullied at all for having a ghost
mom i feel like you know with teen
classic teen embarrassment you know yeah
drop me off around the corner mom i do
you know i don't want my friend saying
you're a ghost
in the similar way that carrie um was
um often mocked i was uh
grossly humiliated growing up yes i was
tormented
people call you like you know what they
called me
you foul smelling rat
oh you you disgusting
bloated misshapen homunculus
they were very articulate yeah
yeah they used a lot of big so you got a
advanced school
urge i think it was a good school yeah
it was a good school we read a lot of
big books we were reading moby dick in
junior high school so they were like
avasti fowl
langpooning you know gestared
that's that i mean but it hurt it cut to
the bone
yeah i mean you can imagine someone with
a razor sharp wit hurts but if they're
razor sharp with wit and a
and you know and like penmanship like
like language yes
seriously that's that's like i would get
notes pinned to my locker
that was act on parchment that had been
written in with quill
really yes calling just an immortalist a
homunculus abomination yes
a pale bloated fetid
i mean in some ways i'm glad that they
couldn't
pick up on your mom's presence because
they might have said really mean things
about her too
she was about to kick their asses and i
had to help hold her back believe me
many many times did you find you know
maybe there were more helpful moments
like if you're on a date or something
you know
you know your mom could lean in and say
you know hey terry you know
give advice yes she did that you know um
when i first dated uh miranda